moment he got married and he had to get
married on 02 22 22. and uh the only
thing i heard was mamet already lost his
wedding ring he kept playing with the
ring taking it on and off taking it on
and off how does that happen what do you
mean where are you that it flies out of
your hand and you cannot retrieve it
uh it didn't fly out of my hand
yesterday i was very nervous sitting
here i'm just trying to make sure
everything goes good in la and when i
get nervous i fidget so i'm not used to
having a ring on my hand i was playing
with it you know sliding it up and down
my finger and then later on in the show
without moving i just looked down at my
hand and it wasn't on anymore and now no
one in this building can find it
assigned people jobs around his wedding
he got in touch with j.d
about making a wedding video that have
35 days that was not that was not my
met's job that was not my best job
it was fiance his fiancee contacted me
asking me to do it i i think people are
very confused what happened was
mary surprised me at my wedding
reception with a video of family and
friends because there were a lot of
people who couldn't be at the wedding
and she was trying to do a nice surprise
for me and it was very sweet
and you know i always played questions
you were right
yeah you know there was lots of trouble
jd was like how the [ __ ] did i get this
job there was a list of 35 people jd
bothered and somehow oh wow jd had to
contact all the people
yeah
yeah i don't know who all my met deals
with and talks to on a daily basis so i
went through the directory uh because i
can't just do like a
uh something to close because yeah
because it would go to my met so i had
to go through like you know all these
different people in the directory to see
who he might deal with who he might know
who you know well listen what a bonehead
jd is he went to upper management and
said should i bother howard with this
request
robin
robin gary and fred
yeah i sent i sent a separate email to
upper management saying hey i don't want
to send this to them i would feel
this is just not my place to do it if
you feel comfortable mentioning it and
uh whatever go right ahead otherwise
that's fine if you don't and that's well
i wish i am angry with you for not
forwarding that request right
i mean get one chris wilding had the
worst reaction to uh
chris says putting jd in charge of it
was gross uh chris felt offended as a
single guy he felt they were rubbing
their happiness in his face
i bet you anything they cut videos i bet
you anything they cut out people's hands
chris i guarantee they didn't and i wish
i'm reading notes last night that jason
is like feeling pressure to be funny and
i'm like
where are you funny in this [ __ ] 10
minute long video where you say nothing
i gotta hear it
out of my guests
howard you should really play this
message cause it's a [ __ ] doozy from
jason and will i defy you to make it
through this five [ __ ] boring minutes
they put together for me
i really challenge you let's go to uh
jason and will we were asked to do this
video by
jd and we forgot about it then we were
asked again and forgot about it then i
didn't forget about it by the way it was
hanging on my head for like a month and
a half and it was driving me nuts
because first of all i thought it was
something they specifically asked like
people that are close to my mat i didn't
realize he asked the entire staff for
the video which is production
yes
remember i didn't even know this existed
you gotta blame my wife by the way if
the video is boring i like i said she
should have edited it down we went fat
for that reason i think that was jd's
job to edit the videos what should i
have kept will which part should i have
capped i showed you're cute
oh my god in the video the kids were in
the video for two minutes [ __ ]
calling the cat into the room my
reception had to sit in there for two
[ __ ] minutes while will is like one
minute the cat's coming
that was just the charge this video was
playing i mean my reception it was like
a great gathering people are having fun
and this video of will and jason killed
the mood like [ __ ] never
thank god it was worth it then